make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up again with
a one shot from the avengers comics from
jason aaron this
is the i guess kind of like the prologue
is what it's called from enter the
phoenix enter the phoenix is the current
ongoing story in avengers right now
we're just not covering or wait until
it's done and then we'll cover the whole
thing but this is kind of intriguing and
the reason why is because i don't really
know
how i feel about this kind of change
that's being introduced here and really
i'm not even really sure how i feel
about the whole idea of the phoenix and
i'll explain why here in a minute but
the important thing about this is that
this initially picks up with the woman
who would become the first host of the
phoenix force on earth one million years
ago basically kind of like in this this
kind of fire pit right not necessarily a
pit that's actually like on fire but
like the burnt place is what she calls
it and the idea behind this
is that like a lot of early tribes and a
lot of early history and humanity
because humanity in its early days was
basically stupid whenever you had beings
that looked different
or seemed different they would abandon
them there in this instance this little
girl was abandoned in this place because
she had red hair and presumably they
considered it an ill omen
and the result was that they just kind
of left her you know left her in this
location of course again
kind of only something that a stupid
person would really do but the idea
is that you have these these kind of
vultures that seemingly show up with the
intention of consuming her and then of
course
wolves show up and then basically save
her following that she's actually raised
by wolves
quite literally she's raised by wolves
she's a feral human being
but it's kind of cool right while she's
with wool she learns to hunt she learns
to track she learns all these important
things
on how to survive out there in the
wilderness and to do what she needs to
do in order to make it but every so
often she would return back to the burnt
place
to try to save individuals she could if
there were people who were left there or
something along those lines and in one
instance where she stumbled across a
baby that was there
she threw a rock at one of the vultures
chased him away only for us to realize
it's basically a cyclops is here
now in that moment she kind of receives
this telepathic message from a being
that tells her like
don't be afraid and then kind of escorts
her back to effectively a safe place now
this individual is never actually given
never really given a name here instead
he's very much presented to us
as a kind of charles xavier-esque
character right this guy who basically
you know kind of existed you know one
million years ago when mutants were
first starting to pop up and then the
result was that he kind of grabbed them
and then took them brought them to this
location and just kind of helped them to
learn how to harness and use their
powers now this is where things are
changing a lot over the course of marvel
comics really with jason aaron and the
avengers
specifically with the idea of mutants
and the reason why is because when you
whenever you go through the history of
the mutant population in marvel comics
what you have here is you have
a woman by the name of celine and celine
was born about 10 000 years
uh well really about 17 000 years ago
during the hyborian age and is by and
large considered to be
the first mutant to exist which is to
say a person who had a gene that
activated and
in turn gave her powers now the idea is
that with celine she's technically
an external um basically meaning that
she has to she's essentially immortal
but
the important thing to understand is
that in marvel whether you look at
uh look at celine you look at
proto-mutants so people like gabriel
shepard whatever the case is
mutants did not exist before 10 000
years ago there are things like the the
seraphim and chiarafem but they're
largely considered to be extra
dimensional beings right i guess they're
kind of mutants but not really but
traditional mutants which is to say
somebody whose gene manifests when they
when they become a teenager whether
through stress or through puberty they
didn't exist before 10
000 years ago this is jason aaron kind
of making making it up and saying
actually they did but the idea here is
that with her being
in this location it basically gives her
the ability to live among her own kind
right people who have powers now we're
not explicitly told this girl has powers
but this really seems to come into play
when she starts getting these headaches
now at 10 years old this is when her
body starts changing and that's usually
around the time when mutant powers will
slowly begin to kind of manifest right
where the mutant gene will activate
somewhere in that time period usually
between the ages of like 10 11
all the way up to like 14 or 15 years
old right during that point when the
body begins to change
that's when the mutant gene begins to
activate and so with that being the case
basically she ends up developing
telepathy but this telepathy comes by
way of her not really understanding what
it is but only picking up on the
emotional
i guess the emotional state of
individuals who are coming for them with
the intention of killing them now the
people who are coming for them are the
ones who are basically
leaving babies in that burnt place right
like just leaving them in that location
because they were too strange they were
too different that kind of a thing and
that's kind of what's going on here why
they they discovered that there's this
group here that's just different and
they just kind of want to kill him right
so basically the 1 million year ago
version of what's going on right now in
marvel comics with regards to the mutant
population right so basically humans
have been hunting mutants for at least a
million years it's basically what jason
aaron's telling us now with this guy who
kind of shows up here he's called the
high walker that's kind of the leader of
the charles xavier s character that's
the only real name we're given for him
he initially tries to use peace and
kindness
and so on and so forth but it doesn't
really work right instead like their
fear
begins to override their senses and
where you end up having this young girl
who basically begins to realize this is
telepathy that she's that she's kind of
uh that she's basically activating
and starts to get sort of angry and
irritated and pissed off and doesn't
really want to leave it leads to high
walker
basically being exposed for a brief
moment only for him to be killed
and that leads the other mutants jumping
in and basically going and you know
getting into a fight with all the
different humans and all the groups
basically both groups slaughtering each
other to the point that this little girl
is the only one left she's the only one
left but for her kind of going forward
from here she realizes
that she basically has telepathy right
now she doesn't quite know what to call
it she's not really sure what it is she
suddenly just knows she can communicate
with her mind and pick up on the
feelings of others the revelation and
the realization of what she has and what
she's capable of doesn't really come
until some future period when she
basically goes back to the burnt place
to kind of sacrifice herself to the
vultures and then in turn
it's possessed by the phoenix force now
this is where i'm not really big on this
great big huge change
not necessarily because i'm against
change right i'm not one of those comic
book fans that just doesn't like it when
things change i'm reading for 20
something years
believe me i'm aware that comics change
what really kind of baffles me here is
it really seems to fly in the face of
everything that made the dark phoenix
saga what it was the whole the whole
idea behind the dark phoenix saga in
marvel comics back in the 80s when
claremont wrote it it was kind of an
answer to the question
what happens if some sort of primordial
cosmic entity that's never really known
hatred or anger
bonds itself to a human being how do
they kind of cope in that situation
jean grey basically you know really the
phoenix force is becoming jean grey
which is revealed at the end of the dark
phoenix saga but but jean grey you know
being a host for the phoenix or however
you want to slice it introduced the
phoenix force to emotions that had never
experienced before
white lust anger wrath different things
like that and the phoenix didn't really
know how to handle it and so it
basically went insane
now there are there have been instances
in the past where the phoenix has
encountered living beings and excalibur
vol 1 issues 42 through
50 i think it was that kind of
introduced the idea of like necrom
and feron and those guys and how like
necrom basically tricked the phoenix
into like creating all these different
pillars and things like that but the
phoenix wasn't actually bonded to a
person instead it was the phoenix being
manipulated into doing a thing but for
the most part the phoenix just kind of
existed in isolation and space
and so having an instance where the
phoenix bonds itself to a young girl
here
and then learns all these emotions
really kind of begs the question
did the phoenix forget when it got to
when it got to the phoenix to the dark
phoenix saga you know a million years of
memories and just kind of forgot what
happened right i mean i have a hard time
believing that a cosmic entity could
forget something
like golly gee when i put my phone you
know it doesn't really work that way i'm
by no means
railing against this it's just one of
these things where i'm trying to find a
way to consolidate and reconcile these
two concepts and there doesn't really
seem to be a way to do it but the idea
behind this is that with this girl being
possessed by the phoenix that initially
rage and vengeance are really what
overtake her right
rage and vengeance against like these
baseline humans right these normal
humans out there
that are basically governed by fear that
the human race because in its earliest
days was governed by fear
it would forevermore be governed by fear
and in truth
that's actually an honest way to look at
it right that despite human sentience
and things like that
the most primal basic emotion of
humanity is fear
in times of desperation in times of fear
and times of doubt people will believe
what they want to believe even if it
doesn't make any sense just because of
the fact that it gives them some measure
of comfort right humans are always kind
of fleeing and trying to find some
measure of comfort regardless of how it
may be but the important thing
is that what she sees here in the base
level of humanity and kind of
looking out into the future of what of
what awaits humanity is it's always
going to be the same thing right like
this
this fear of things they don't
understand is going to govern the very
nature of humanity from now going
forward as she ponders the idea of just
wiping it all away right of literally
just wiping out the entirety of the
earth of ending all life on the planet
and then just kind of letting it start
over right because that's kind of what
the phoenix force does the phoenix force
gets rid of things that don't work
why it does that i don't know it's an
answer grant morrison gave us and it's
one that marvel never bothered to
clarify so that's
it that's the only real response that we
get but the the end result of her
really ending the entirety of humanity
comes by way of
of one of the wolves right which
basically licks her hand and in that
moment she kind of experiences kind of
brings her back to an era of kindness
right where
these wolves could have killed her
instead they took her to raise and so
it's kind of interesting because animals
are cool people or
are really cool humans suck like that's
kind of the perspective she gives us
peeta would absolutely love this girl
but the important thing here is that she
really kind of backs away right she
moves away from this concept and so at
some point in the future we're not
really given a definitive time frame
that the phoenix just aged this girl up
to basically you know basically
adulthood but she ends up traveling
directly to asgard and one of the
funniest things that we get is that you
have odin trying to lift the hammer
mjolnir which you can't do because this
happens after he put the sentient storm
inside the hammer and so the hammer now
has a will of its own and just doesn't
want to be lifted by odin and so where
all this is happening suddenly the
phoenix 4 shows up here
and starts laying waste to all the
forces of the of the asgardians and when
it busts into where odin's at the
phoenix basically says you can call me
the phoenix right i'm putting a team
together to save the world
from itself and from people like you and
me are you
in so this is really kind of how the
phoenix and odin
first met each other which is really
kind of a crazy question because the
thing that i would ask here
this is really the question that i would
have to ask is thor really the child
of odin and gaia or is thor the child of
phoenix and odin that's my question
because i feel like jason aaron's gonna
change that and if thor is actually the
child
of the phoenix force that would enter
that would bring in a whole
new level of power it'd be kind of
bonkers but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
uh if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
do
you